going live and we're live what's up hot
breath averse we're here with you boy
guinness the doll guinness thanks for
hanging out everyone this is a special
treat we do here on hot breath for all
you comedy writers out there this is our
special right ten podcast this is where
every week we'll share some writing
insights and tips and tricks and
different experiences and we're all open
to learning from each other so this is a
great way to do that so this one was a
very interesting topic actually this one
arose in my class this week I had a
student who at the beginning of class
just asked Joel what do you write about
when you have nothing to write about and
it seemed like usually when one of my
students asked me a question I feel like
it's a question that is resonating with
several other comedians especially
starting out or comedians going through
some sort of creative block so I wanted
to share with you kind of my method for
overcoming that writer's block and
really the number one way to do it is to
just start small and incremental and
really don't even try to write funny
don't even try to be funny
step one is just to get the pin to the
page that's it like I have done on here
before the write tin challenge where I
challenge you to write for 10 minutes
every single day but hey you know what
if 10 minutes isn't realistic
start with 5 minutes start with a line
writing is a muscle and the more you use
it the stronger it will get the better
you will get at writing the more
effective and efficient your writing
will be but especially as comedians we
can get caught up in trying to write
funny all the time and trying to force
the funny and trying to create magic
every single time we show up to the page
but realistically it's the law of
averages I remember interviewing
Thompson
on here he said one out of 20 things he
writes it actually ends up worth keeping
so just keep that in mind that
especially comedy writing it's a numbers
game the more you write the more
opportunities you're giving yourself to
hit that note if you will to find that
next joke to find that next idea so the
more you write clearly just the more
opportunities are going to have to find
that next bit that we're all eagerly
chasing towards and so just take the
pressure off and just start small and
incremental all right it could be just
writing a line every day you wake up and
you just write a line or even a little
bit more um in general don't try to
write funny don't try to be funny just
write it literally like journaling and
I'm someone who's nine years into this
game and a lot of the things and a lot
of times I write
I'm not even specifically writing jokes
I am specifically just showing up to the
page a lot of it is just journaling some
days I'll journal a page and that's all
I got for that day other days I'm
writing for 30 or 40 minutes like at I'm
a big fan of just the law of averages
and just knowing if I can just show up
every single day and something good will
come out of that so just think of it in
those terms think of it writing as a
muscle the more you use it the stronger
it's going to get the better you're
going to get but it really does come
down to take the pressure off take the
pressure off you go out to shows and
you're like oh well so-and-so has an you
know hmm
if there's one thing I haven't learned
from doing almost a hundred and seventy
interviews with some of the top comics
in the game it is to keep your eyes on
your own paper don't get caught up
looking to the left and right you know
focus on your lane don't be looking at
everybody else that's where the traffic
is if you're looking at someone else's
Lane that's where all the traffic is
was on your lane and it's only your
speed so wasn't that a fun little
analogy there huh I wrote the Hat this
morning in my jury no I think that was
Dan Pasternak that told told me that in
this Center and his interview on here so
what do you think Guiness all right
that's my dog's input on writing so for
this week even just start small and
incremental for the next seven days just
show up to the page however you do it if
you write an entire page if you write
just a single line just find the small
victories and they will snowball into
the big difference but it really does
even when you don't feel like it you
gotta at least put in those reps I mean
if you want to be a comedian you know
and that is a thing with this game is
that people are like oh I want to do
comedy I want to do comedy and then you
get into it and you're like oh so you're
telling me this is work I thought it was
just magic I thought I just showed up
and then was magically funny and it was
all easy
spoiler alert comedy is hard but it is
also worth it so just put in the time
right with other people as well that can
be a good way to shake it up if you're
finding writer's block and just trying
to sit at home or going out and just
trying to create something on your own
maybe collaborate with other people you
know there's such a big power and
teamwork and really collaborating
especially in comedy so if you're
finding you're hitting a roadblock a
good way to overcome it and that get
outside of your comfort zone maybe if
you are writing at home maybe go to a
cafe Mitch Hedberg would go to like
Target and other places he said that had
a lot of crazy it was a crazy static
environment that forced him to just kind
of bring something out of his sense of
humor so get out of your comfort zone
get into a new environment go outside
yeah go to a cafe go to a bar just go to
a museum don't even try
to write specifically about your jokes
you can go out in public and if you go
to museum you could write up write some
funny jokes about the paintings are
seeing or if you go to target you could
write funny jokes about some of the
people you're seeing or some of the
products you're seeing so with our
material specifically it's like our baby
and we hold it so preciously and we want
it all to just be perfect but getting
your mind outside and starting to kind
of exercise that a different muscle
within your writing body of work really
when you come back to your comedy
writing about your joke specifically you
find new angles and new inspiration any
new capabilities I think that'll really
surprise you so if we're gonna kind of
put an ice cap on this if you're feeling
this rider block one don't try to be
funny just show up to the page start
small start incremental small
sustainable attainable goals so if it's
just show up right up write a line cool
you did that for that day or if it's
right five minutes or if it's right ten
minutes I like the ten minute goal
because ten minutes it's it's just a
sliver of time out of your day but it's
still enough of a time block to where
you're like oh yeah this is great I'm
writing there about halfway through
you're like oh I'm still writing and
then after ten you kind of it's enough
time to go through the whole arc of like
doubt and like why am I even doing this
to breaking through that resistance
because the more you break through that
resistance the weaker that resistance
gets so starting small starting
incremental another one don't even try
to be funny just right just journal if
you can't think of anything to write
about start your writing off that way I
can't think of anything to write I
wonder why this is maybe it's all the
drugs that have killed my brains I
remember the first time I did drugs I
was in high school under my front porch
with my buddy chance what are the
chances I said the name chance but you
see now you went in just a couple lines
from saying I have nothing to write
about - now you
writing about something very specific
and personal to you so in just starting
you'll be amazed where you end up but if
you're like I don't have any new jokes
okay well are you writing oh well then
there you go you're not giving yourself
a chance to get new jokes and if you're
wanting to be a whatever your goal is if
you're wanting to achieve it are you
chipping away at that every day and just
a little bit of writing every day is a
very effective way to chip away at that
so don't try to be funny
start small and incremental get outside
of your comfort zone and just go out and
write in a separate public place just
get out of where usually right shake
things up so in comedy there is a power
of threes I think that is a great top
three ways to overcome writer's block so
start small and incremental don't try to
be funny try new environment those are
three very attainable ways that you can
break up your writer's block for you
here so I hope you found this valuable I
think we can write a blog about this we
did just pusta we did just post we just
boosted sorry that was my dog guinness
saying that we did just launched our
website hot breath podcast com we have
blogs over there we have our episodes
over there we have merch over there as
well so hot breath podcast calm is a
great way to start connecting with the
hot breath averse more and seeing all
the other great content we have going on
if you want to hear a specific theme of
a write 10 podcast holla at your boy
Joel Byers comedy at gmail.com that's a
great way also I want to do alive
I want to do a Q&A here so if you have
any questions you want to send Joel
Byers comedy at gmail.com is a great way
to send that or connect with our
Facebook group hot breath comedy Network
just search it on Facebook and connect
with me and other members of the hot
breath verse so congrats
hop brethren system we made it to the
end of a tight tight tin a write tin
podcast so
kudos to you for out here on the comedy
grind keep it up
anything I can do to help you along the
way feel free to reach out it's so great
to be connecting with you out there
honestly that is my favorite part about
doing this is when someone comes up I
just met a local Atlanta comedian last
night named angel who came up and said I
love the podcast and I was like you just
made my whole life so anyone else out
there feel free to reach out and connect
and let's grow and get better at comedy
together and we'll see on the next and
in the meantime I'm listening to Rodney
Perry's episode this week if you're
looking to become a professional
comedian he drops all the gyms so that
is it I love you all cool